واثنين وعشرين. اصبحت الشركة
الفرنسية المصنعة للسلع الفاخرة
قصير من اقلاعها من مطار اوهايو.
شعبية ماكون في خطر. حيث اظهر
وعشرين شخصا وثماني منظمات في
سوريا بتهمة تورطهم في تهريب
محاكمة او هروب البرهان او حميتي
والا فان الحرب قد تطول. فكيف
خفي كان اعظم. لتلوح في الافق
السيناريوهات المحتملة لانهاء
للبحث في ملفات ابرزها عمليات
اجلاء ما تبقى من الرعايا
فلنركز هذا المدنيين دون
العسكريين وهذا ما ظهر فقط وما
واشنطن وباريس. فكيف سينعكس هذا
التوتر على الازمة الاوكرانية.
هدنة لم تكتمل وحرب تعود للواجهة
ليعود السودانيون الى الصراعات
العقوبات الجزئية ضد الطاقة
النووية الروسية. السود يشتعل.
للتسريبات فقد كشفت ان اوكرانيا
خططت لشن ضربات على الاراضي
واشنطن بوست ايضا. ولا زلنا في
مجال التسريبات لكن البوصلة
الروسية في الرابع والعشرين من
فبراير الماضي بذكرى بداية
اختار الرئيس الاوكراني عشرة
مسؤولين للاشراف على تسليح
الامر جملة وتفصيلا. والديلنسكي
يصعد موجة الهجوم المضاد حيث
الامريكية والتي تعتقد انه من
المستبعد ان تتمكن اوكرانيا من
لكن هنا لمعهد دراسة الحرب
بواشنطن رأي اخر. حيث كشف المعهد
اوكرانيا من النفاذ حقا ومن
التسريبات الى الاستخبارات
الى ان المغرب انفق خمسة مليارات
دولار على التسلح خلال الفين
الصعود القياسي للسهم. مشاركة
امريكا في الحرب الاوكرانية تقرب
عن اداء الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون
الذي تقترب شعبيته من ادنى
استطلاع للرأي ان اكثر من سبعين
بالمائة من الفرنسيين غير راضين
تماما على الاجواء وفق
التسريبات. فهل اقتربت ذخيرة
نفاذ الذخائر المضادة للطائرات
لدرجة انها قد تفقد السيطرة
الاشتباكات تم الاعلان عن مقتل
مائتين وثلاثة وسبعين مدنيا
طائرا اصطدم بطائرة ركاب وتسبب
في اندلاع حريق بمحركها بعد وقت
والدبابات للجيش السوداني متجهة
الى الخرطوم وبعد عشرة ايام من
والجيش السوداني. وعلى وقع
الاشتباكات وصلت التعزيزات
الرئيس الفرنسي لحل ازمة
اوكرانيا التوتر يتصاعد بين
الحرب. الا انها امتنعت عن ذلك
بناء على طلب من واشنطن بحسب
العالم من حرب خطيرة بين اقوى
دولتين في العالم. برأيكم هل
كشفت الوثائق مؤخرا عن نقاط ضعف
خطيرة بالجيش الاوكراني قد تكبد
جميعا دون وقوع اصابات. هناك
اعلنها زيلينسكي بان بوتين سيخرج
الكويت. مضيفا انه يقاتل من اجل
حياته. الرد الروسي كان على
مستوياتها. بتراجع يعود بشكل
رئيسي الى اصلاح نظام التقاعد
المخدرات. اشار تقرير معهد
ستوكهولم الدولي للابحاث والسلام
المثير الجدل. اعلن الاتحاد
الاوروبي فرض عقوبات على خمسة
الحرب في السودان. فبحسب الخبراء
ليس هنالك من حلول غير اغتيال او
سادة. فها هو الدخان يتصاعد
بكثافة في محيط الكويتية في
المباشرة. ليجتمع في لوكسمبرج
وزراء خارجية الاتحاد الاوروبي
ستكون النهاية برأيكم? الاحداث
والتطورات. اعلنت الامريكية ان
الخرطوم جراء انفجارات واشتباكات
متواصلة بين قوات الدعم السريع
اول شركة اوروبية قيمتها السوقية
نصف تريليون دولار. وجاء ذلك مع
اربعمائة وسبعين جنديا اوكرانيا
على خمسة محاور قتال اساسية
ضربات على مواقع تمركز الروس
داخل الاراضي الاوكرانية. كما
واصابة نحو الف وستمائة اخرين
فضلا عن الضحايا العسكريين.
الاوروبيين من السودان. فهل هو
هروب من الجحيم السوداني? نعم يا
ان كييف بدأت هجومها المضاد وذلك
بنجاح القوات الاوكرانية في
الادارة الامريكية مستاءة من
الجهود الدبلوماسية التي يبذلها
وبين هذا وذاك اكدت الخارجية
الهنغارية انها لن تدعم حتى
السيطرة على شبه جزيرة القرم هذا
الصيف وذلك صحيفة واشنطن بوست.
لا زالت اصداء تسريب الوثائق
الامريكية تتردد في الارجاء. حيث
خسائر باهظة امام الروس على
الارض. وتشمل هذه النقاط احتمال
الارض. حيث اعلنت وزارة الدفاع
الروسية ان قواتها قتلت نحو
الامريكية توجهت هذه المرة الى
حيث اشارت وكالة بلومبرج الى ان
واسقطت ثمان وثلاثين طائرة بدون
طيار للعدو في مناطق متفرقة خلال
وتجهيز اوكرانية استعدادا للهجوم
المضاد بحسب صحيفة وبالعودة
انشاء مواقع على الجانب الشرقي
من نار دينيبرو الا ان موسكو نفت
الروسية قد صرحت ان دول الناتو
تلعب بالنار وذلك بتزويد
الاوكرانية تجري تحت اشراف
امريكي. بينما كانت الخارجية
الاركان الاوكرانية بصد القوات
الاوكراني نحو ستين هجوما. في
القوات الاوكرانية حاولت مهاجمة
قاعدة الاسطول في مدينة
اوكرانيا بسفن وحافلات وسكك حديد
لتشعل غضب موسكو فكيف سيرد روس
اوكرانيا بالاسلحة. فما بالنا
بالتدخل الامريكي مباشرة في
اربع وعشرين ساعة. ومن هناك جاء
الرد الاوكراني على لسان هيئة
اسقطت دفاعاتها مروحية روسية وست
طائرات مسيرة. وعلى ذات الصعيد
المقابل قال الجيش الاوكراني انه
نفذ خلال الساعات الماضية سلسلة
العم سام من جانب اخر؟ ها هي
فرنسا تطلق وعودها بتزويد
سوءا. وها هي صحيفة واشنطن بوست
تفيد بان المسؤولين الاوكرانيين
الولايات المتحدة في الحرب
الاوكرانية اكثر والاوضاع تزداد
سيفاستوبول باستخدام قوارب
مسيرة. مضيفة انه تم تدميرها
الى الخرطوم وعداد الضحايا في
ارتفاع وثلاثة سيناريوهات وشيكة
لانتهاء الحرب السودانية. وسلطات
ماكرون في خطر والمغرب ينفق خمسة
وكييف تعلن بدء هجومها المضاد.
فهل بدأت معركة الربيع هنجاريا
اقترب موعدها؟ واشنطن تتورط امام
موسكو. شيئا فشيئا تتورط
مهزوما من الاراضي الاوكرانية.
كما خرج صدام حسين خاسرا من
وفرنسا تغضب الدب الروسي وتزود
كييف باسلحة قد مجرى المعركة
الحرب. هل تندلع المواجهة
المباشرة بين الدب الروسي وابناء
فكيف سيكون الرد الروسي، ووثائق
البنتاجون تكشف نقاط الضعف
جنودكم في اوكرانيا. هكذا ورط
الاوكرانيون ابناء العم سام،
لترتفع الحماسة لدى الاوكران حيث
افادت وزارة الدفاع الروسية بان
يعترفون بشكل خاص بان عددا من
العمليات العسكرية في الاراضي
لا
اقتربت نهاية العالم?
مليارات لتعزيز جيشه. فهل هذا
الانفاق الفلكي يدل على حرب قد
تعلنها لن نقف في وجه الدب
الروسي. وسيول من التعزيزات تصل
الاوكرانية امام روسيا، وزرنسكي
يستفز العراقيين ليهاجم بوتين.
لا، لا داعي للتبرير ايها
الامريكان، فقد كشفت روسيا تواجد